[Music]
it's time for our scene an unseen
segment where we peer behind the big
culture stories of the day and this week
features Maxine Waters response to the
State of the Union and it was on be
et-plus a claim by the star of The
Passion of the Christ that the sequel
will be the biggest film in history I'm
joined now by Fox News contributor
Raymond Arroyo of the wheel Wilder
series Raymond first be et featured a
response to the State of the Union a day
after the State of the Union well you
can't timing can't be perfect Laura and
this was Angela Wray who is introducing
Maxine let's watch in case you miss
y'all's president State of the Union
last night spoiler alert you missed
nothing of course we won't spend all our
time together in lamenting about the
walking disaster that is the KKK
commander-in-chief she joins our special
tonight to deliver a rebuttal that will
seal the lips on that Oh Donald Trump
calls him out whenever he appears on TV
there should be a disclaimer that says
this may not be acceptable for children
she she should have had the disclaimer
for the host of the show and as long as
a potty mouth we cut out some of the
others cut out the other lose her
disclaimer well first of all it was
Maxine Waters didn't did a child make
the backdrop for that said I thought for
a minute they went to alive in the
parking lot of the Capitol where's the
car park that's like a white cabin
understand that but there's always
understatement with Maxine Waters right
he'll and he'll never be presidential
right
yes and he'll never be presidential
let's watch the next one he's not
presidential and he never will be
presidential he claims that he's
bringing people together but make no
mistake he is a dangerous unprincipled
divisive and shameful racist we deserve
better that's why I have called for his
impeachment some believe it's too early
I disagree
the time is now what do you say after
that
dude they should just have a number for
all of the insults it should be like
well and then he's 143 I say it all at
this point I'm going to impeach the
president you have to have grounds for
impeachment now I don't like him he's
mean he's angry he's upset and the other
thing this is Black Entertainment she's
not entertaining actually sort of
entertaining the mildly but I would have
preferred Madea doing political
commentary yeah that's a great idea he
would draw a crowd and actually has an
audience and he'd be funny well okay
let's let's go let's go to the the
resurrection Mel Gibson is going to do
the sequel to The Passion of the Christ
which made more than a billion dollars
six hundred million dollars at the box
office only thirty million to make I
mean it's a yeah but it's one of the big
the biggest r-rated films of all okay
but let's go to the resurrection now how
did this come about Jim Caviezel did an
interview with USA Today where he said
this is going to be the biggest movie of
all time he said and the media is now
going wild the Today Show said has Mel
Gibson really been forgiven the guy won
a Golden Globe last year for hacksaw
wait wait the Today Show that they've
been dealing with is wondering whether
Mel Gibson has been free has been
forgiven let's let's watch what Mel said
about the resurrection let's watch it's
not just about a resurrection it's not
the you know man comes back walks
through walls has holes in hands eats a
bit of fish you know it's not that it's
it's a it's a big it's a vast
theological experience I think you need
to delve into what that means in a way
that you take that as the centerpiece
and you juxtapose it against many things
that go on around it and in other realms
hmm so that you you have to under it
gets pretty wild it's like an acid trip
but
I think we're the Saints it's okay okay
you have a spirit guide to take you
through yeah that's why they call him
madman
yeah there's much more to say about this
we'll do it in the days ahead and he's
told me this is about the fall of the
Angels the prophets much more than just
the reservoir